so like how much time does this play
like take like planning to like
execution
um
like a month or so we had about a month
between when i pitched the idea and when
we did it and even then like we were
changing
the route kind of like whilst we were
cycling as well
like because google maps
just like there was if you cycle in
tokyo there's pre-existing cycle routes
yeah yeah that can tell you where to
cycle but in wakanda and stuff like that
no one cycles there
we didn't see people no one's there well
no one's there period
like after we left work and i we just
didn't see people for like four days
yeah
there was nothing yeah and um
like
it was just so much prep so much and
like i was trying to do work and do
other streams whilst also trying to
manage everything and also i didn't
really promote it that much right i was
kind of like yeah it's happening and in
hindsight i should have promoted it way
more because i'm like this is like eight
days i should have promoted this
yeah yeah exactly exactly
but i was also terrified that if i
promoted it too much
and then the first day and the first day
just had no signal right because i i
genuinely thought like the first day of
cycling i would just have no signal for
half the day right i kept telling the
viewers as we were leaving work and i'm
like listen
if there's no signal for like two hours
i'm so sorry it's probably gonna happen
just just deal with it yeah and it was
like terrifying because you're like man
it really [ __ ] sucks to have your
first day of in a big event yeah just
not just not work and the technical
issues how should you convince people to
then just you know stick around yeah if
they don't if they don't invest
themselves in the first day a lot of
people can fall off yeah yeah yeah yeah
because what happened is it was kind of
like a
like that in viewership right right the
first day was crazy we had like 27 000
viewers right i don't even know why
like people were going crazy like i
think all our energies were really high
as well because the first day yeah chris
was chris was really really funny the
first day and was energetic slowly went
down
i'm sure he'll talk about that
same with me to be honest i mean for the
first five days i was killing it and
then i started really slowing down right
um and yeah and so
i've got all the questions
just how was your how was the experience
that that was it just was tough
preparation yeah the hardest part like
getting all the the widgets and stuff to
work
but like that's why i did like two days
before i did a
test stream in tokyo yeah where i did a
60k cycle across tokyo but obviously
it's not really like the same because
tokyo is like perfect internet yeah i'm
like there's never worry that it would
cut out because like tokyo has like it's
like mcdonald's everything irl streams
just work it because it works so well in
tokyo you really have to be like in like
a weird basement or some kind of room
that's made of aluminium foil yeah
exactly i said aluminium
yeah
no no you said it right you said it
right you said it right connor
wasn't a mistake with that i don't know
i was gonna say aluminum
uh yeah and i'm sure there'll be like a
really big video out i don't know if i'm
gonna do one or two parts or whatever
yeah but like it was it was a lot of
prep it was so i wish i could show the
prep because the prep was crazy and like
shout out to my uh my uh mods and slash
programmers
who uh worked
really [ __ ] hard on making the final
monkey app i think that was the coolest
part for me yeah yeah yeah i think
watching i mean he just had a custom map
it was i thought it was [ __ ] sick
that you could just
see like the map it was zooming in and
out gradually showing you where i was
yes like kind of go i just thought they
were sick and a progress bar like a
progress but that's so [ __ ] cool when
i watch the tour de france i'm like
where are they i don't [ __ ] where's
the progress ball
dude tell me the tell me that give me
the progress bomb that's what i need
what's that like actual current speed on
a gps yeah give me like i want like look
like make it like a game yeah make it
like i'm just i won't watch tour de
france unless there's a hud
i i had like a heads-up display right
like if two of the friends had chat
i'm watching that yeah you know what i
mean two other friends needs this dude i
like you know what i want like the
hearts display how much health they have
left oh it's it's it's it's so [ __ ]
weird because um because i i've also
been streaming more often this past
month i'm trying to try to dabble in
more often i'm kind of getting used to
it right
but then like a few days ago i had to
like stream like a let's play yeah and i
was like great this this can be easy all
right i've been doing let's plays for
this past month yeah and everything like
that yeah and just like but it was like
an offline let's play so no chat just an
og offline let's play yeah and i i tried
i tried like i thought it was going to
be easy because i was like i've been
streaming like i've been streaming games
streaming different things like almost
like every day for like the past month
whatever this is going to be easy i turn
on the game
and i like subconsciously look towards
where the chat is i see no interaction
i'm like
what the [ __ ]
is everything better and i just i
actually had to like scrap the video
because i was like i don't know how to i
actually don't know how to like
commentate or like be entertaining
something to interact you know what's so
weird though i actually find it easier
when there's no chat no no no no because
i because early in my channel i did
let's plays yeah that weren't on stream
right so like i because i'm used to that
from early on in my channel because i
was a one point of let's player yeah i
just find it so much easier when there's
no chat for me for me chat
i'd be i might be thinking about like uh
you know something you know like okay
i'm gonna say like this joke here right
yeah like you know explain this or
whatever yeah but while i'm doing that
on stream because i'm so engrossed in
looking at chat i all the jokes just fly
out of my head so i become such a boring
let's player on stream i just read out
the funniest thing chat says and i just
say say as if it's my joke
so that normally works really yeah
to me like i i think my big issue is
that when i don't have when i'm not live
streaming and when am i just trying to
record like an offline video second
channel video whatever um i like think
about what i say too much yeah so i try
i try to like script it in my head you
know what i mean whereas if i have you
generally yeah yeah yeah i turn into
like giggup right whereas if chat's
there i'm forced to say what's the first
thing that comes to my mind right i
don't i can't like second guess myself
so i just haven't forced like constantly
talk i'm like a firm believer that
as a streamer your chat should be on
screen i just think it always should be
on screen oh yeah of course i just think
that like that's the whole live element
right show them like it doesn't have to
be like crazy not like nico nico where
it's like flying across the [ __ ]
screen yeah just put it in the little
corner like all right imagine if you
could like i think it's stupid that the
olympics don't let people like stream it
yeah imagine if you had like twitch chat
with the olympics i think that'd be
awesome i think we've said this before
on trash taste but like that's why like
i really really wanted all this stuff on
on the screen yeah the cycling things
i'm like cycling is like inherently
you know it's not that you know it's not
that exciting yeah like it's just not
like if i was just cycling pov across
japan it's like right
cool yeah nice like walking the same
it's like give me something like yeah
give me some stuff to get invested true
gamer you're just
you're turning irl into a game well
that's kind of what i wanted it to be
like i kind of wanted it to be where
anyone could hop in and kind of get a
feel for what where we're at yeah you
know that's like oh how far in are we
it's like
we're eighty percent of the way there
yeah oh uh we're we're eating lunch and
we're 47 of the way there oh the days
just started with five you know what i
mean like yeah a lot of the questions
people are going to ask uh in the chat
and stuff like that just get that out of
the way there's never any questions
about how we're doing how's it you know
it's like you can everything is visually
explained
and and it doesn't impose i think it
adds to it because it's not like there's
much i need to show yeah it's literally
just uh yeah me and like i i had like a
a fail proof for like everything um
except a spare bike which i nearly broke
of course you did of course like my
brand every new bike
i was smart though i got insurance on my
back okay that's good that's good that's
good we learned from ourselves the
insurance was like
it was like twenty percent of the bikes
[ __ ] cost but it covered everything
it was like if the bike literally come
bust or get stolen yeah yeah and i'll
replace it it's monkey proof yeah
literally like no matter what i do to it
it is
they'll no questions asked yeah yeah
yeah and it's great for me because if i
was live streaming i broke it i'm like
it's proof
right here bro
oh yeah i nearly broke it on the second
day it's not good
was that when you fell over or yeah yeah
i was pointing to something in the
distance holding on with my left hand
and i went over a big rock right thing
like wobbled yeah and i just went right
into the yeah the pavement and it was a
really big like it's not maybe like this
big sidewalk from the road pavement for
british people um and i just like jumped
into the bush because i didn't want to
land on the sidewalk oh yeah i was like
that's just gonna hurt yeah but i didn't
also want my bike to get wrecked so i
just didn't in the second i was like i
just can't decide i'll just jump
but i i was also excited
my first time ever using them i had the
clip in yeah yeah yeah which are awesome
by the way it makes cycling like way
easier and also you have to think less
you have to worry about where your legs
are you just
yeah like like a steam engine just keep
you just keep pushing you don't like the
machine yeah i mean like i'm sure to
work with chris is on but he's just like
slipping and [ __ ] yeah yeah like it's
just it's good but also it's bad for
situations like that yeah but luckily uh
if you jump hard enough you'll get out
of the clips
and i think i did and they've made a
good clip it was completely by accident
and luckily there's no cars on the road
right at that point uh i mean we're in
the middle of nowhere yeah yeah but yeah
it was it was you have to be pretty
unlucky to get hit by a car
on a road that's practically empty that
would be tough that would be tough i
mean there was that that was an aspect
that was really
uh you get used to pretty fast it was
very anxious the first time where you
cycle on the road oh yeah
and tunnels especially yeah
tunnels is terrifying yeah cause the
echo in a tunnel when you're cycling in
it is terrifying right right because the
car comes in here in the background
like 15 000 echoes coming right that's
terrifying you and you know it's coming
from behind you and you're like oh no oh
no please please don't don't hear me
don't please please
i don't have your lights on yeah he's
like please see me please see me plea
and you're literally just hoping you
just don't die yeah that's it
hoping it's not like because i saw like
one one of the clips where that massive
truck yeah almost clipped you or
something
that was that was unnecessarily scary
because it was literally a
a country road with so much room and no
one no one was on these roads and he
went so close to me and i thought why
why just being addicted like
i i it was enough room
probably in europe it's probably the
normal amount of room yeah but i was
just like come on man it wasn't like it
was like a busy road like i don't know
that that was probably not as close to
some other ones but other times we were
on a road and i chose to be on the road
because
when you're cycling for ages going on
the the pavement the sidewalk it's bumpy
and up and down and [ __ ] paved and it's
just not good and after a while you're
just like i just wanna cycle i do not
wanna have to think or get my ass hurt
or stop or slow down you just wanna keep
you just wanna have the exercise bike
experience yeah
right and you go so much faster on the
road yeah and it's like whatever i don't
give a [ __ ] about the cars even when i'm
driving i don't give a [ __ ] if i have to
just like wait a second to get around
the cyclist it's a road bike let me go
on the road yeah also my favorite part
is when i saw other japanese cyclists
and we just nod at each other that was
fun
yeah you you acclimated now every other
cyclist that was like also wearing
serious gear would not
it was like a mutual respect you'd wave
especially when like i don't know like
you
uh you were coming down like
you were going up a big hill and after
yeah yeah they they knew and you're like
oh nice like oh he ain't annoying
he's one of us
yeah just like one night we had to drive
back um
[Music]
we did drive down the biggest incline we
did right and in the car we were like
this is stupid i can't believe we cycled
up this yeah it's like ten we're like on
this road for like 10 minutes driving
down we're like this we cycled up this
this is insane yeah because like day one
the first incline we're like dying we're
like we can't do this this is too much
and by like day seven you're just like
all right let's get used to all right 5k
incline let's do it let's just go you
just get used to it it's like it's like
it's just a different sensation you
don't like it doesn't hurt nearly as
much yeah just kind of like
it just uses a different part of you